Our extracted DNA sample that's been amplified, so
we have enough of our sample to do
something with. are we ready to go sequence
it now, is that what we're going to do?
>> So the the process that your DNA undergoes at 23Me
is a little different to sequencing.
It's called chip hybridization or genotyping.
>> And so how does this differ from sequencing? What's the difference between
sequencing and sort of, what you mention is sort of chip hybridization or
for, for genotyping? So you can think of sequencing
as just reading the genome from beginning to end
almost, you want to know every single letter and what
it is. With genotyping, we actually decide beforehand which
parts of the genome, which letters are interesting to
us. And then we specifically look at those letters,
with the knowledge that these are the letters that
maybe cause diseases or are associated with some, trait that
you have.
>> I see. So, so you actually have to put a lot
of thought into it beforehand to sort of know exactly which positions, which
bases, which letters you're interested in.
How, how many letters do you actually,
or how many bases do you look at in, in an individual sample?
>> So we look at about a million, on the current 23andMe chip. that
means that when you get your results back from us you can download a million
different calls or base pairs from us.
>> Sequencing sounds like it gives you a lot more information. what are
the prohibitive aspects of sequencing? Why doesn't
23andMe do sequencing? Yeah, sequencing is definitely
the future of this field, and we we're definitely interested in sequencing when
it gets cheap enough, but the main advantage of genotyping is cost. so we know
that to get the same results that we get with the 23andMe chip, we would have
to charge at least ten times more with
the sequencing product. Probably a lot more, I don't
know. Genotyping has other advantages as well, we,
because you genotype using the process of hybridization,
you actually get a lot of different shots
on goal if you like. You get to hybridize
different molecules. many times.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And you get the, the sum of all of those.
>> I see.
>> Or the average of all those reads. So you
get a lot of information compiled into one data point.
With sequencing you might actually miss the part of the
genome you were interested in. And that could be a problem.
>> I see. So in, in a way you kind of have Higher confidence,
even though you have maybe more limited
information in the end, you have a higher
confidence about the actual, you know, letter or base result for that position.
>> Exactly, and some people describe genotyping as almost like
single base sequencing, where we're seq, we're sequencing hundreds of
thousands of molecules. On each part of the chip. So
there's an advantage there that's hard to replicate with sequencing.